El guapo Jack va a comprar un poni de diamantes.
El poni cuesta "p" pesos y Jack también tiene
que pagar un impuesto del 25%
sobre los ponis de diamante o el
poni de diamante que va a comprar.
Haz coincidir las expresiones con sus significados.
Cada significado puede coincidir con más
de una expresión.
Bueno, tenemos que nuestro primer significado es, el precio del poni de diamantes antes de impuestos.
Pues nos están diciendo que cuesta "p" pesos,
así que la "p" que es el precio del poni va acá.
La segunda es, la cantidad de impuestos que
tiene que pagar Jack.
Bueno, nos dicen que los impuestos son el
25% sobre el precio del poni,
así que de lo que sea que cueste el poni, esta "p", se
tiene que pagar un 25% de esto.
Otra forma de verlo, es que este impuesto
es igual a .25 por "p", este es el impuesto.
Bueno, el tercer significado, cantidad total
que pagó Jack por el poni.
Bueno, pues esencialmente va a ser el precio del poni,
más lo de impuestos que tiene que pagar, así que es "p" más .25 por "p", ésta coincide.
Pero si nos fijamos en las demás, vemos que
esto, "p" más ".25p"
es lo mismo que 1.25 por "p",
así que ésta también coincide.
Y las otras tres expresiones pues no coinciden
con lo que nos están preguntando,
así que las ponemos en ninguna de éstas.
Vamos a checar nuestra respuesta...
En efecto, todo está correcto.